starwars the rise of Skywalker has the
unenviable task of wrapping up the
latest Star Wars trilogy uniting a fan
base that's become increasingly divided
and concluding the decade spanning so
called Skywalker saga that's a lot for
one film to manage does it pull it off
well yes and no the rise of Skywalker
should have been Leia's movie on solo
got the spotlights in the force awakens
and Luke Skywalker's story dominated the
last Jedi with the rise of Skywalker it
was Leia Stern unfortunately carrie
fisher's tragic death in December 2016
made a big Leia showcase impossible
forcing JJ Abrams to cobble together an
arc for the princess turned general from
old outtakes it's not perfect Leia's
dialogue is noticeably vague and it's
obvious that Abrams is using a stand-in
when Leia space is hidden she doesn't
have any standout moments the climax of
her arc is a little vague and much of
her plotline is carried out by other
people talking about her not what she
actually does however it works pretty
well land it's much bigger than a cameo
Leia is in multiple scenes and she has a
complete arc in the movie obviously it
would have been better if Carrie Fisher
was still around to give lay out the
send-off she deserves
given what Abrams had to work with
though playas final on-screen appearance
is significantly better than we expected
the last entry in the skywalker saga
begins at a breakneck pace and it
doesn't slow down to breathe until the
film's final minutes in order to set up
its end game the rise of skywalker
introduces new characters new planets
new gizmos and new ideas so fast that
it's impossible to keep track of them
all
every new plot thread introduces a dozen
questions at episode 9 simply doesn't
have time to answer well reports differ
depending on who you're talking to it
seems pretty clear that Disney and
Lucasfilm didn't plan this new Star Wars
trilogy out from the beginning in the
rise of Skywalker that decision catches
up with them the first half of the movie
while full of action is mostly set up
for the second half it would have been a
lot better as some of those ideas that
suddenly show up in episode 9 had been
seated throughout the previous two
movies
[Music]
as it is however one film has to do a
lot of heavy lifting and there's not
quite enough room returning characters
like r2d2 and Rose Tico barely make an
impact new characters like dominic
monaghan SPO Mont kin and Naomi a Kees
Janna hardly register at all it all
makes for a very bloated and
unsatisfying viewing experience there's
a version of this movie that's much
tighter but unfortunately it's not the
one we've got you know who steals
practically every single scene he's in
in the rise of Skywalker
c-3po for one Luke's fussy protocol
droid is funny or an episode 9 that he's
ever been
but he also proves surprisingly vital to
the movie story even in a new hope c-3po
is mostly around to translate for r2d2
this time c-3po translation skills are
instrumental in moving the plot forward
if you told us a few years ago that
episode 9 would have a steering up over
c-3po a lifelong comedic relief
character we wouldn't have believed you
and yet here we are did you like the
last Jedi if so sorry
the rise of Skywalker does a very good
job dismantling pretty much everything
that movie put down supreme leader snoke
surly demise as it turns out he wasn't
really that important the near
extinction of the resistance it was only
temporary when we rejoined them they
found a lot of new recruits Rey's
parents well put it this way they were
definitely somebody the rise of
Skywalker buries its predecessor in a
way that feels petty sacrificing lots of
set up and unsatisfying passion
the only thing from episode 8 it really
keeps are the poor's finn rey poe and
kylo Ren are the best things about the
new Star Wars trilogy even when the
script lets them down these actors are
so charismatic that it's fun to just
watch them run around quip bicker and
get into trouble the rise of Skywalker
gives us a lot of that and it's just as
fun as you'd expect
even though finn still doesn't have much
of an arc ultimately though the film
hinges on the relationship between ray
and kylo thankfully Ridley and Driver
are more than up to the task the
chemistry that the duo shared in the
last Jedi is cranked up to 11 here and
the two actors carry the movie given how
bonkers the plot is that's a massive
feat going into the rise of Skywalker
fans had some major questions now that
it's out they still do we never learned
how Palpatine came back to life he just
is raised true nature comes out of
nowhere and isn't adequately explained
and many key plot points are glossed
over completely the movie constantly
tells us that things happened but it
doesn't tell us how or why you may
recall that the force awakens did the
same thing where'd you get that a good
question for another time granted some
of the Disney produced spin-off
materials offer a few clues but viewers
shouldn't have to do extra research to
understand the basic plot of a movie no
matter how much Disney wants that to be
the case JJ Abrams went big with the
rise of Skywalker and if he didn't quite
stick the landing he certainly at least
tried it's a movie that's full of
spectacle the dog fights the lightsaber
duels and the blaster battles are bigger
than anything we've ever seen in a Star
Wars movie before and the Easter eggs
cameos and nods to past Star Wars films
pop up everywhere it's hard to think of
a better tribute to Star Wars especially
given the final scene which takes us
back to where everything began the rise
of Skywalker is bold ambitious
convoluted messy hopeful over odds and
complicated in other words that Star
Wars in a nutshell this is it Luke Leia
Han c-3po r2d2 and Darth Vader are done
for now at least it appears we finally
know how this story ends the same seems
to be true for our new heroes too none
of the main actors involved with the
sequel trilogy seem particularly keen on
coming back for more
and given the rise of Skywalker's
definitive ending it's hard to imagine
that their future adventures will be
quite as exciting as the one that just
concluded true Star Wars isn't going
anywhere
Disney will crank out new material set
in a galaxy far far away for decades to
come still it's just not going to be the
same without our old and newer friends
at the helm thanks for the memories
folks may the force be with you check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about Star
Wars are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]